Wow! Is that a traffic light?
Yes that is, he's our friend.
We all should follow his signal to be safe on the road.
I can tell you all the traffic lights.
Good, go ahead.
Our friend here will give us different signals...
...and you can tell me what each one represents.
Okay.
Now the signal is red it means stop.
You are right when the signal turns red, we all should stop.
Oh now, it's green.
It means we can go.
Yes Jimmy, you are correct.
When the traffic light turns green, we can start walking or we can start driving our cars.
Hey, now it's showing yellow.
I don't know what to do.
Yellow light means wait...
...it tells you that either you will have to wait for the red light or for the green light.